is our planet reaching the point of no
return with global temperatures rising
and natural disasters intensifying this
question is becoming ever more relevant
but is this question also being
politicized Dr Stephen coonan is a
theoretical physics professor and former
undersecretary for science in recent
years he's been criticized for his
stance on climate change an effort to
separate the politics from the science
join us to hear his take on what climate
science tells us what it doesn't and why
that matters welcome everybody to
another exciting edition of the into the
impossible podcast it is I your formerly
fearful host Dr Brian Keating joined
with a very very special guest today all
the way from New York City it is Stephen
coonan A renowned physicist and more
recently involved in government policy
and also Urban studies of a kind and
we're going to get into all that welcome
to La Jolla great to be here Brian and
chatting with you we have so many things
to talk about today we're going to talk
about your wonderful book which is
provocative which just controversial
which is Technical and chock full of
information we've had on many many
climate
scientists and and those who are
interested in climate change just from a
human perspective we recently had on Kim
Stanley Robinson who's written many
books about this who's an Alum of UC SD
as it turns out and we had on Tim Palmer
last year who shared the Nobel Prize I
believe back in way back in the mid
2000s along with Al Gore and I think
maybe we'll start with the book as we
often do because when you see a book
you're never supposed to judge it by its
cover but my audience knows I love to
judge books by The Cars because what
else do you have to go on you know when
you don't know the author I know you
very well your reputation is is Titanic
explain for my audience please the
choice of title the subtitle and most
delightfully the art on the cover as
well right so let me start with the
title
um you know in retrospect fact I've come
to understand it's really a triple
entender it refers primarily to the
state of the science that there's an
awful lot we don't know about climate
science it refers to how I felt and how
many other people feel when they're
exposed to what the U.N for example or
the research literature says about what
we know and what we don't know and then
finally it refers I think to the
uncertainty about what we're going to do
about all of this growing human
influences on the climate so that's the
the title if you like a major motivation
for writing the book was to expose
non-experts to what the ipcc the U1
climate panel and the research
literature really say about what we know
and what we don't know which is very
different than what you get from the
media or the politicians or other
activists who are talking about comment
as far as the cover art goes I know very
little about that I was given a set of
possibilities uh pick one I consulted
with a lot of people and this is the one
we came up with I very much enjoyed this
book I listened to an audio we had the
physical hard copy and you know
discussing it in detail I think is
necessary for an audience like mine it
is an erudite audience the most
intelligent audience in the known
universe as I like to say and I want to
take it back as I often do to my hero
Galileo and Galileo said the following
our job as scientist he said is to
measure what's measurable and to make
measurable what is not yet so and your
late great colleague at Caltech my
former advisor and Mentor Andrew Lang he
quoted that on the occasion of the the
induction of him and his team into the
linsayan society which is what Galileo
would put on all of his books
um what do you make of the ability of
climate scientists to to both utilize
the methods of Science of hard science
of data acquisition and collection much
of which a lot of which is done here at
Scripps but also to maybe make inroads
into Politics as Galileo did
unintentionally so what do you make of
the highly politicized nature of this
because I don't have this in cosmology
nobody wakes up and says I hate that
constellation over there that's a
republican constellation I will not look
at it why has it become so politicized
it is atmospheric chemistry which is
derived physics tell me Steve there is a
real science at the heart of all of this
it's actually a wonderful science that
mixes up physics and biology and geology
and chemistry and so on and as I have
learned it over the last 20 years I've
become a fan of it I think it's great
and we can go into some of the
challenges and and so on but I think
um what has caused it to come a Cropper
if you like or become so politicized is
that the implications of it if some
people are correct uh mean that we need
a radical restructuring of the way
Society Works globally in order to
reduce greenhouse gas emissions and find
other ways of using energy many
scientists in the business though not by
no means all have come to mix up their
role as informers and advisors with that
of persuading and trying to dictate
policy and I think scientists cross the
line when they do that yeah I call them
political scientists
now one of the things that I very much
enjoy about this book and I emphasize
quite frequently with controversial
guests that come on with with those that
don't believe sort of quote unquote on
the standard narrative or the accepted
narrative that is settled science as
obviously the book connotes uh uh this
uh this you know dissension from that
opinion but um but the you know the
notion that we should listen to experts
and that there is uniformity of experts
um and even if there's a preponderance
of experts I mean the the statement by
by this gentleman Albert Einstein that
you know when a hundred scientists came
out against the theory of relativity
said if it were they were really right
um but of course we have people like
your former colleague at Caltech uh
Richard Feynman who would say things
like you know science is the belief in
the ignorance of experts so what do you
make of this what does a lay person to
do or maybe an educated layperson
technically minded layperson we are
dealing with a heat wave they tell us of
on you know unrivaled proportions and
yet that wasn't predicted last year in
other words we we we're living through
you know supposedly the warmest year on
record maximum records in Palermo Sicily
just yesterday
um uh 25 days of a heat over 110 degrees
in neighboring Phoenix
um what what does a educated person to
do when confronted by seemingly
disparate facts and evidence local and
predictive how do we assess all of this
so so I teach climate science at The
Graduate level at NYU and I'll start
teaching again in a month or two uh and
what I tell the students is first of all
uh it's a mix actually of Engineers and
business people I tell them read don't
read the summaries don't read the Press
read either the ipcc summaries or go
look at the data yourself okay and then
judge from that
um and eyes get opened up when they read
for example there are no long-term
trends in hurricanes as you can find in
the ipcc report a lot of confusion is
about weather versus climate the
official definition of climate is that
it's a 30-year average of weather
properties averages extremes variances
and so on and so anything that happens
in one year or in a given year is not
climate so for example California has
been in drought for the last 20 years or
so that's climate but then you get last
year Deluge of biblical proportions
that's whether unless it continues for
so many months uh so many years so
you know the the tricky thing about all
of this is that the weather has natural
cycles in it the El Nino is probably the
most familiar cycle but then there are
longer term Cycles periods of 60 70
years which uh you know are probably
called climate Cycles uh such as the
Pacific decade of observation the
Atlantic multi-decated isolation and so
on and you can get food
I like to show as you can find in the
book the record of the height of the
Nile over almost a thousand years which
the Egyptians were able to compile and
what you see is that there's tremendous
variation from year to year but there
are multi-decatal Trends and so in the
beginning of the record starting at
about 6 30 A.D you see it go down for
about a hundred years and no doubt
there's some medieval Egyptian climate
panel saying New Normal new normal as it
got drier and drier and if they just
waited 100 years it comes back up again
so this is one of the challenges in the
science to distinguish the natural
variability from the response to human
influences my particular interests will
be an astrophysical constraints and
we'll get to those in a minute but just
to point out I often go down to visit my
friends that have a much nicer view on
the coast of La Jolla Cove that are
based at the Scripps institution of
oceanography which is you know
co-recipients of that same 20 2006 Nobel
Prize with vice president Gore at the
time uh and uh and there's a picture and
it shows the very first building which
comprised the very first academic
institution in La Jolla California and
that is the Scripps building the
directors building or their office
building and in the background you can
see La Jolla Co and you see these are
famous sea caves and whatnot right and
you see Scripps Beach which is a
protective thing and the sea level and
those are taken in 1905. the sea level
hasn't changed at all I mean it actually
completely identically flat no very
variation and this is like you can see
the evidence right outside your window
if you're down there so to what extent
should we pay attention when we hear
things like you know Florida you know
coastlines are going to be underwater
and Manhattan's going to be you're going
to be you know uh kayaking to work next
year in the village
um what you know to what extent should
we be mindful of truly planetary scale
phenomena of which you know sea level is
a certainly very very important metric
to what level can those be tied to
physical observables that may be
predictable yeah so the prediction is
quite a separate matter you start first
by asking what has been changes at the
global level or at Regional level over
the last 120 years or so which is about
as long as we've got good records maybe
140 years or so if you go back beyond
that you've get into historical records
and then even further back you've got
paleo proxies tree rings Lake Walsh
things of that sort okay so we all have
a relatively short record and we do see
changes on the multi-decative scale in
that relatively short record I described
for you the uh the Egyptian uh height of
the Nile but Global temperature has
certainly gone up we've gone up about
1.3 degrees since 1900
um and that rise is not monotonic it was
Rising pretty rapidly from 1910 to 1940
was flat or slightly declining from 1940
to 1970 and then has been going up again
since about 1980. so that alone will
tell a scientist or even a non-scientist
that it's a lot more complicated than
just CO2 was warming the planet because
the CO2 was increasing steadily during
that time but the temperatures going up
and right I mean oftentimes I see things
like oh it's the highest temperature
ever set a temperature record last set
in in 1947. well well then why was at
range or not 1847 and that kind of
brings up the notion of what we call you
know Mountain Quiz bias or or a form of
sample variance bias that were attentive
to things that we can measure uh as
Galileo said you should make measurable
which you can't measure and we don't
have built-in CO2 detectors in our heads
so by making it measurable what extent
is correlation conflated with causation
so so the ipcc when you read the reports
as opposed to the summaries
um very carefully distinguishes between
the detection of a change which is
relatively straightforward if you've got
the data versus the attribution of a
change to human influences let's say
rising greenhouse gases that attribution
is really tough
for two reasons at least maybe I'll
think of a third but I've got two at
least one is it's a very noisy system as
we've said the second is that there were
these natural long-term oscillations as
opposed to the forced response and then
the third is that human influences are
physically small
the planet absorbs and re-radiates its
heat about 240 watts per square meter of
sunlight that comes back out as long
wave infrared radiation the human
influences on that net of CO2 and
aerosols and methane and nitrous oxide
and so on is about two and a half watts
per square meter so we're talking about
a one percent change in the rated of
balance of the planet and you might say
well that's not a big deal on the other
hand if you do astrophysical estimates
one percent to 300 Kelvin is three
degrees and so the numbers are about
right we worry about three degrees
and but it's a small number which means
you're in the noise as far as other
influences go and often we see these
plots the famous Kealing curve of course
derived here by uh killing killing oh
you did oh wow fantastic so his um uh
well I want to get into him and his son
knows who's currently a professor here
because I've heard wonderful Talks by
him that are persuasive and I think you
know it's very interesting to to get
into these discussions let's first take
a giant leap backwards let's talk about
um your theoretical physicist by
training what is a model and you know
how does it differ you know we talk
about the standard model of particle
physics we talk about models of
cosmology that I study in my my
graduates is what is a model and then
what by what metrics can we really
apprise the goodness of fit of a model
in other words we talk about sigmas and
we're doing this lots of sigmas and what
is a sigma what is a Model A Sigma is a
measure of uncertainty either in the
data no measurement is perfect there's
always some range of likelihood uh for a
given measurement and then the models
does not just one climate model there
are about 50 of them and they don't all
give the same answer and so you can have
a sigma or uncertainty in the model as
well and so we're trying to compare two
uncertain quantities how did the climate
change over the last 80 years and how do
the models predict or just describe that
change over the last 80 years because
all right so let's talk about what a
model is in the present context it's a
large computer program
that follows the motion of air water
momentum energy radiation through the
atmosphere and in the ocean where you
also have salinity and currents step by
step through of order 10 million voxels
uh for a hundred years and tries to
describe the gross features of the
climate system jet stream Gulf Stream
deserts Hadley cells things of that sort
and then it tries to say if the CO2 goes
up how are things going to change so
that that one percent uh change in the
radiative balance and that's a very
difficult problem to do in part because
it's a big computer problem but more
importantly the size of the boxes you
can make in the model is only about 100
kilometers on the side all right and
there's a lot that happens within a box
think about thunderheads for example
which are a few kilometers long you
can't describe those explicitly and so
you're going to have to make an
assumption about how many clouds are
there where are they in the voxel when
do they appear when do they just appear
because that affects the sunlight and
the infrared radiation different people
make different assumptions and so you
get different answers behind you is a is
a vial there's a large Beaker and that I
collected when I was at the South Pole
right in Antarctica right uh the second
time I've been there twice on occasion
of the national government sending me
there and uh all expenses trip for the
bicep experiment that's cosmology
tremendous work that's done there
including samples of of air of ice cores
that go back hundreds of thousands of
years and monitor the signs of climate
you know CO2 impact it goes back to what
Iranians
1800s the infrared activity yeah and
then hey this is going to change the
climate they thought it would be a good
thing that's right yeah this was from
Sweden maybe not surprised that's right
yeah no Nobel is or preferentially
biased towards swedes
um so when I look at that vial now I'm
reminded of some recent talking points
that I'm seeing online that we have a
Six Sigma deviation to the negative of
Antarctic ice shelf thickness as
measured by our extent rather as
measured by these satellites that do
such things
um and it's it's just obvious when you
see the trend and I'll put a picture up
on the for the viewers and listeners to
the podcast on audio can find it on my
YouTube channel Dr Brian Keating uh but
if you can if you can speak to that what
level of you know kind of uh concern
should we have when you see a number
like Six Sigma it's it's it was good
enough for Higgs to to win a Nobel Prize
right
um so what what do we make of this as a
theoretical physicist you'd be delighted
if any of your projects yeah the problem
is that you know today's Six Sigma uh
happened uh many times in the past okay
so particularly with respect to ice and
we can maybe talk more interestingly
about the North Pole at some point but
uh you know things change a lot the
planet currently is
coming out of well we're not sure what
it's coming out of but it's in what's
called an interglacial
if you go back
20 000 years uh the planet was mostly
covered with it why not mostly but there
was a lot of ice on the planet and the
great ice sheets extended down to
Chicago or even New York
um and if you go back even further 125
000 years ago those ice sheets were had
retreated
um basically they were less than what we
have today the planet was a degree
warmer and sea level was six meters
higher than it was that's called the
emien period all right and those
variations which are pretty cyclical are
driven by astronomical phenomena the way
in which sunlight falls on the earth the
Earth's orbit the tilt of its axis and
and so on so we shouldn't at one level
be real surprised that we're losing ice
right now in terms of returning to an
astronomical topics my favorite subject
besides me and is uh the the net amount
of carbon is not it's not infinite uh
there's a certain amount of uh
biological material which was deposited
you know millions or perhaps you know
even longer hundreds of millions of
years ago and even according to anyone
who is a firmly believing in the
anthropogenic and carbon dioxide you
know a modulated global warning they
will say under oath it will say yes
there's a fine there's a limit to how
much carbon we can't produce where there
is not an infinite store of carbon in
the earth
um or crust and we don't have access to
it to that extent what you know what are
the kind of astronomical or planetary
scale phenomena
um it it's it's been calculated I heard
Charles David Keeling was the son of
Ralph Keeling right and he spoke about
this he first brought to my attention
that there is a finite amount so to what
extent do we have to worry about
reaching the complete combustion of that
carbon converting to carbon dioxide
before say we reach what I call you know
clean energy escape velocity in other
words at some point we will have Fusion
we'll we'll talk we're going to talk
about that we're going to talk about
Fusion we're going to talk about high TC
superconductors because you I can't
resist with a physicist you know I'd
love to nerd out and we will and it's
very pertinent to this climate
discussion
um but to what extent do you know can we
make it kind of stretch the Glide where
we're never going to burn all that
carbon but even if we did there's some
upper limit on how much we're going to
burn before we hit escape velocity and
just everything is except for Rockets So
This is where the real world of
economics and Technology people in the
fossil fuel business which is what
carbon is in the ground oil gas and coal
talk about a supply curve namely how
much oil or gas or cool could I get out
of the ground at today's price with
today's technology and the answer is
we've got known carbon in the ground
known in the sense that you could invest
in it uh we've got about 30 or 40 Years
of oil let's see and you might say oh my
God we're going to run out
but in fact you know what's called the
resource as opposed to the reserve the
amount of stuff you could imagine
getting out with better technology or at
a higher price that's a hundred years at
least okay so we're not running out
anytime soon but it may be that the cost
of extracting it will go up and at some
point it becomes more economical to get
your energy some other way so we will
not run out but as you know the famous
quote that the Stone Age didn't end
because we ran out of stones all right
so
um
the carbon in the ground is so much more
than what we use right now that that's
not going to be a major factor so you
brought up you know fossil fuel also
companies I'd be remiss to say that you
didn't you know participate and you
weren't involved with British Petroleum
for some years and
um what do you say to those people out
there like your fellow professor at NYU
uh Professor Scott Galloway who's in the
stern school he said uh quote science is
uniformly on board with the climate
almost what you might call you know
extremists and only the right wing
lunatics deny that this is settled right
so what do you say to Scott yeah so so
what I would say to Scott is if you've
read my book Scott you'll see that
everything I say is right out of the UN
reports and or the research literature
and so if you think I'm denying
something uh tell me what I'm denying
because I'm quoting to you the official
science Scott your problem is you
haven't read the ports in any detail
that's right so getting back to the to
the you know question of of human
Innovation and when we will we're using
different types of stones you know glass
and and metal and and so forth silicon
silicon Stones right petrochemicals
petrochemicals right so I always say you
know that um when people and lately
there's been a tremendous amount of
interest in extraterrestrial life and
it's a fascinating topic and we do talk
about this quite a bit on this channel
but um but besides that I always wonder
you know for a spacecraft to get here I
claim if we were going to go space
faring and they were to ask us when we
get to you know Planet blorcon 7. they
would ask us how did you get here what
was your technological pathway and at
some point we'd have to describe what a
whale is right I mean there's no way
like solar panels don't come from solar
panels we didn't build a microprocessor
using microprocessors so we had all this
primitive technology so my question is
you know how much
um How likely is it that another
civilization exists that that has fossil
fuels it has some form of Prebiotic or
pre you know Advanced uh life forms and
that that was then used over geologic
time scales maybe involving plate
tectonics Etc but but How likely are
these planetary phenomena ubiquitous
throughout the universe is a question
I've always had so the laws of physics
We Believe Are In fairness that's right
I hope so including the laws of
chemistry that's right uh which are much
more Rich than the physics laws but
anyway
um and you know the only a finite number
of ways to get energy out of the
universe you got radiation photons
you've got the rearrangement of atoms
you've got the rearrangement of protons
and neutrons uh you've got gravity and
we pretty well have tapped into all of
those in one way or the other so I would
be very surprised if we came on a
civilization that had yet another way of
getting energy out yeah and because it's
a precursor you can't build uh Fusion
reactor unless at some point you had
fossil fuels at least in our timeline
yeah I've talked with Professor Adam
Frank of University of Rochester about
this and he's claimed that we should
look for as a techno signature we should
look for global warming on another
planet we should look for CO2 wow okay
it's hard to be able to do that all
right we have a hard enough time
measuring the temperature of our own
Planet well maybe not global warming but
carbon dioxide that would be carbonyl
because we know because it just carbon
left over molecular oxygen things like
that is it true that there are much more
powerful sources of atmospheric forcing
functions like methane water vapor isn't
as a greenhouse gas what level do you
think that these people who are so in
the climate you know kind of leading to
catastrophe caused by human beings
settled science so-called Camp how how
do you respond to them when they they
seem to have multiple agendas like one
agenda that I'm hearing a lot is um is
what I call or or what just seems to be
like kind of anti-natalism where they
want to have population control and this
is very reminiscent of you know the
1970s when when this was uh Ehrlich and
others yeah they were complaining about
Rome and all that yeah who won all these
prizes of course and and uh deep
population seems almost like a more a
more pressing concern so some of the
some of the concerns that I've heard
about this book or complaints about the
book is look you say things there's some
fixed fraction of the of the Earth's
population who are going to die uh
whatever that means are going to be
killed by again this is their
terminology no you don't say that but
but you make a forecast or there are
forecasts in the book and people make
this how many deaths can be attributed
to global warming so can you speak about
that let's talk about the deaths which I
talk a little bit about it that's right
let's talk about what has been first
rather than what the projections are and
there's a actually now I think two
articles in the Lancet which is a
reputable uh medical journalism at
globally the deaths attributable to
temperature extremes over the last 20
years
and what they find and I I've referenced
the paper in in many talks I've given uh
it's right there anybody can look at it
is and I'll make up the numbers
approximately because I don't remember
them exactly about 5 million deaths from
2001 to 2018
uh globally 5 million were attributable
to temperature extremes of those 5
million 90 percent were attributable to
extreme cold
and 10 percent were attributable to
extreme warmth right but there's no way
to Target you know let's let's have some
warmth targeted to Minsk you know where
these deaths are taking place right no I
mean but you know to say that the
warming of the globe is causing more
people to die right is a true statement
right it but it's not factually complete
it's not because it's also causing fewer
people to die from cold and the net
actually is that there are more people
alive because the globe has been warming
what do you say to people young people
um I don't know if you have children but
but I do and
um you know I hear a lot about the
following that we should the actually
the best way to reduce the most
effective way is not reducing the number
of flights not reducing the amount of
meat that you eat not uh you know
driving less and carpooling more buying
electric cars having fewer kids and I
always get concerned about that because
I I think there's a not you know
significant gap between that and saying
saying well if more people died it would
be better for the climate or if you know
people climate suicides and and there
are deaths of Despair now and there's
tremendous psychological damage
occurring to children because of climate
um climate you know some call it
hysteria so so how do you react to that
say to your kids
um is uh again I don't know them uh but
what I've taught my kids who were 30
some odd years old is that there are
only one and a half billion of us in the
developed world the oecd countries all
right we live a wonderful Lifestyle on
average
um there are six and a half billion
people on the planet whose theme or meme
is not enough not enough energy not
enough food not enough transportation
and so on and it is immoral to deny them
the energy that they need in order to
live a better life and so I would say to
your kids gold spend some time in
Nigeria or in the poor parts of South
America and then tell me that we should
be cutting back globally on energy yeah
okay so in the book you make a very
interesting set of logical you know
syllogisms one is that you know in order
for this to truly be catastrophic you
know it has to be caused by human beings
it has to be
um you know unavoidable irreversible and
uh and and so forth so there are several
different premises of the book
um which seem you know Prima facia in
arguable like if humans aren't
contributing to it then humans can't
necessarily solve it unless we you know
kill every cow well I mean adaptation is
a solution I want to get to that so so
here's so one theme that I believe is
attributable to in the book is that
there's no plausible way to reduce the
CO2 contributions to the atmosphere now
I wanna I wanna just before you respond
I want to say if you if that is your
contention what if I tell you that there
have been two recent breakthroughs uh
one of which I talked about with your
colleague Charles seif NYU and that's
nuclear fusion and then today's news
which I've talked about with my
colleague Jorge Hirsch here many times
uh and that is high TC super Canada let
me tell you God hands you a letter says
Steve guess what I've got good news and
I've got good news we've got high TC
super connectivity ambient pressure and
we've also got nuclear fusion and it's
they're about six years away and and
better yet AI is going to control
everything and so put up AI in charge do
you stand by that we can't vacuum out or
you know decarbonize the atmosphere I
mean uh if I had wings I could fly right
okay the the thing is I think there are
two things here does the science or the
technology exist okay and we can talk
about ITC or Fusion but the second is
it's got to be better than the
Alternatives economically and ability to
scale we can produce
um you know electricity right now from
Fusion uh it's just a question how
expensive is it going to be and will it
scale same as true fission by the way
it's a little more expensive yeah but
you know if you're willing to pay the
cost
you can run the whole country or the
whole world on wind and solar but that
would take so much resource away from
other things we need that it's a values
question for the world do you want to do
that versus giving more Refrigeration to
a few billion people pivoting off of
that my question wasn't only directed
towards the supply side of the carbon
equation it was also the negative a
subtraction in other words if you had
infinite free energy on top could you
suck out and how would you do it have
you started to talk about the carbon
cycle for a second okay every year there
are about 200 gigatons of carbon that
flow up and back from the surface of the
planet into the atmosphere and then back
again
that 200 gigatons is caused by the
growth of vegetation it's caused by
absorption or desorption in the ocean
and so on
um and it's just about in equilibrium We
Believe or at least it would be except
for the fact that we're taking about
nine gigatons a year of carbon and
adding it to this annual cycle so if you
could make a small perturbation in that
annual cycle by making plants grow
better for example you could counteract
uh some of the emissions maybe all of it
so that's one and people are trying to
find fast-growing plants and so on the
other way of doing it is to capture it
thermochemically out of the air direct
air capture as it's called there again
it's a question of economics and scale
the current cost right now is a couple
hundred dollars a ton of CO2 removed and
we're talking about gigatons uh and so
you quickly quickly get up to big
numbers now yes you should work on
technology and so on uh but it's not
there yet I wonder if you have a take on
the you know if you can perhaps react on
a fit from a physics level the
resistance of fission I I view that as a
tell because you'll see people like the
famous you know
um know-it-all Greta thunberg talking
about will no nuclear can't be part of
the solution and to me and others that's
kind of like you know you're drowning in
the ocean if you really think you're
drowning you know they all joke you know
you don't wait for the helicopter you
know God says you know I sent you a
helicopter I sent you a boat I said uh
but but uh what do you make of the
resistance sufficient I mean is it all
just like Three Mile Island Chernobyl
and Fukushima or is there something
deeper at work so there is we shut down
the reactors you probably saw them
shut down Indian points two million
dollars a day to store the weight so
what do you make of this so
um there's a very nice book by uh
Spencer weird who is a historian of
science
um and I think it's probably about 40
years old called nuclear fear and it
talks about the Deep
psychological fear that many people have
of powerful forces that are invisible
and you shouldn't be messing with and he
takes it all the way back to the
Frankenstein myth right or do not do not
reanimate and so on and I think a lot of
people uh that's a fear all right
um I think also
um that personal fear radiation I don't
understand it there are issues I think
soluble of what do we do with the spent
fuel not waste spin fuel
um and but there are people who are
starting to understand the realities of
energy uh Schoenberger
um a Seward brand have come out and said
yeah we have to do Vision I mean it's
certainly it's the only one that's you
know planetary scale we could actually
power incredible cities and 20 percent
of U.S electricity already built uh more
in France it's 80 rougher 70 something
we haven't built a reactor in this
country in a long time we've just got a
couple of new ones coming online right
now I think the technical Innovation
that's needed there uh is twofold we
need to be making reactors smaller the
typical reactor size is about
1100 megawatts people are talking about
reactors that are 100 megawatt scale so
that's kind of the scale in a naval
vessel
um build them in a factory
um standard design not like the big ones
which are um you know each uh bespoke
um and then the economics will be a lot
better but you know it really depends
how much do you value being carbon free
all right if you don't want to be carbon
free you probably don't need it but if
you care about carbon emissions then
it's absolutely essential let me take a
little detour here I I am very close
friends with the person we have in
common Paul steinhardt who's also been
on the podcast and uh Paul has been
accused of being a Multiverse denier
um I reacted to a book that makes such a
claim it talks about
um uh the and not by a professional
physicist it talks about the you know
the all the evidence for the Multiverse
um I'm blanking on the name although I
did review it for physics today about
three years ago so but it didn't leave
the greatest impression on me but he
talks about Multiverse deniers
um I found that in my review I said that
it evokes uh you know kind of a word
which should not have its currency
devalued not just because of my personal
connection to you know people that
perished in the Holocaust but uh there
is a very uh consistent thread of people
that accuse you of being you know a
climate change denier what does that
mean and how do you react to that yeah
you know I think it means that I don't
buy into the narrative which you can say
in a few words right that we've already
broken the climate and it's going to get
a lot worse unless we do something uh
rapidly and on a long scale
and I think when you read the science so
what as I mentioned what's in the book
is not my science right it's right out
of the official U.N science so please
tell me what am I denying I guess what
when I've heard it criticize
um in particular was that uh the data
are not it's not saying it's Cherry
Picked it will say you took an uh AR on
these um uh assessment reports right so
but then AR sex came along and it showed
that actually there's not it went from
low confidence to mild confidence so how
do you how do you react to that it's
always going to change okay so it's
always going to change
um the um book was written before ar5
came out so I quoted af5 I make in the
book you know references to some of the
research literature that was included in
AR6 and I'm pleased to say they say more
or less the same things I said
um there's probably you know in the
works and update uh which would but
there are essentially no things in there
that I would change yes some of the
specific wording is different in ao6 but
the fact that there's no long-term Trend
in hurricanes that Greenland is melting
today no more rapidly than it was 80 or
90 years ago that sea level rise remains
on a long-term basis at uh three
millimeters a year I mean those are
things that were in ar5 and they're
there in ao6
so uh one of your former students
apparently Mark boslow wrote a review
which I I felt was a series of straw men
and women maybe that get uh get torched
so it says
um unfortunately unsettled is a book you
can accurately judge by its cup well
thank you uh Mr Bosler Dr Boswell baby
because you know that's my signature
stock and trade as we open the opposite
he may you make use he accuses you of an
all strawman concocted by opponents of
the climate size in the 1990s create an
illusion of arrogant scientists bias
media and lying politicians the phrase
signs to settles repeated as a Target
phrase it seems like he only read the
title uh Boga science is settled
rhetoric so he's really just taken into
account the title and the um and
essentially the this notion that these
things are you know constantly in doubt
and never or never in doubt and always
in error as Landau used to say about
cosmologists
uh searches dude come up with uh but
there are many there are many examples
of physical problems that are difficult
to model so a lot of the criticism I
heard from Lawrence Krauss who's been a
guest on the show he wrote a book a
climate uh on climate change Tim Palmer
we're going to get to him in just a bit
um some of the courtesism I get is
Steven thinks he's better at modeling
than we are or he thinks that we are not
as good as the modeling that is
necessary and sufficient how do you
react to those criticisms well the
modeling is what it is all right and
again I quote what's in the book
um let me say a word about Mr Bosco
first or Dr Boswell um he he was in one
of my classes if I remember right yeah I
don't think he was ever actually a
student in the sense that yeah it's not
a graduate center right but he tosses
that and yeah of course
um and the review he wrote unfortunately
was really light on science I mean I'm
happy to respond to specific criticisms
coonan says X but in fact it's Y and you
will find on my medium page some really
detailed responses to some of the main
mainstream climate scientists who
criticized me and I think I've responded
effectively do I know more about
modeling than those guys no absolutely
not they know more but I do know
modeling all right and I do know in
other spheres what a good model is and
what isn't and also what these
certainties and uncertainties are and
again I just repeat what's in the book
The Last and most kind of ludicrous
claim in this in this article by Mr Dr
Boswell third is climate scientists not
deniers that have been compared to Nazis
and perpetrators of genocide in fact it
was Creighton Michael Crichton himself
and his in the appendix to his book
state of fear who directly equate and I
don't know climate scientists eugenesis
but I mean but wait it is true there is
climate hysteria that is leading people
to not have children to not get married
and to consider having you know uh
basically being becoming you know
sterilizing themselves so that they
don't have children so I mean that it
maybe it's not eugenics in the Nazi
sense God forbid but but at a certain
level he's saying that that you are in
the camp that is is accusing the the
good guys I'm not accusing anybody of
anything at the science level right I am
accusing some of the prominent
scientists the journalists the
politicians and some of the scientific
institutions of misrepresenting what's
in the official reports or the research
literature and I give in the book and
I've given subsequently many examples of
that which are really tough to deny so
the Scientific American also which is
you know no longer a real state of uh of
Affairs that it used to be when I was a
kid I used to I loved it I loved it I
had the amateur scientist I used to
build the experiments the mathematics
yeah I love it I love that that's really
Fallen uh out of favor but um but their
critique is that um you know that the
two such statements by kunin follow the
pre the simple Preamble for the
literature and government report
summarize and say heat waves in the U us
are now no more common than they were in
the 1900 that's one thing they're taking
issue with and the warmest temperatures
in the US have not risen the past 50
years I mean what I mean it's these are
just data points right so it should be
you can find it you can find them it's
not your personal data right no it's not
my personal data it's it's just the EPA
I can give you the URL you can see the
graph yourself I have to say Steve I
mean the the low level of intellectual
kind of Engagement of both of these
things for the first one by boslos is is
predicated on the cover and the name of
the book and this one is predicated on
the first two pages of the book yeah
it's clear look I try to read every book
or listen to every book uh but certainly
something I'm going to be uh going to be
talking about with the author but
certainly if I'm criticizing a book say
the book about Multiverse tonight I
think both the Scientific American
article and a fact check that was done
by climate feedback I think
um
they were criticisms not of the book but
of a review of the book all right and so
the Scientific American folks put words
in my mouth that are never in the book
right at all and yes I think the most
disappointing part of all of this is
that we have colleagues who are
nominally accomplished scientists who
are behaving in ways that we'd probably
throw our students out uh if they
behaved that way let's go back to models
so um the past three years have seen an
incredible uh amount of both trust and
scientific institutions and great
skepticism uh more or less predicated on
the veracity of bottling and I think you
know in the case of Tim Palmer who's
been a past guest and and delightful to
talk about
um but he has called for an is in
agreement with you that we need better
models and I think he talks about the
state you talked about the size of these
voxels which are the three dimensional
analog of a pixel it's just
two-dimensional and getting those down
to kilometer scale so his words that
requires a CERN you know our Manhattan
Project Style effort which is nowhere in
sight and would seem to then require you
know government government scale
investment what do you make of a CERN
for climate change how do you react to
his will to spending a lot of money on
climate modeling already I think it's
misspending a lot of it because they
spend Cycles on doing silly runs for the
ipcc about different emission scenarios
um let's talk about computational
requirements first okay
so naively you would think that well you
need 20 30 layers up in the atmosphere
and another 15 down in the ocean uh but
it's the horizontal size of the voxels
that really determines the computational
load it's currently 100 kilometers if
you shrunk it to one kilometer that's a
factor of a hundred linearly a factor of
10 to the fourth quadratically but then
you get another factor of a hundred
because you got to make the time steps a
lot smaller from the current condition
so we're now talking about a factor of a
million all right it goes as the the
cube the cubic of that right all right
and you're going to wait a long time
before you got a computer that's a
million times more powerful than the
exascale machines that are at the
Forefront today so I think Computing is
going to develop for its own reasons
um you know national security reasons in
the U.S other things and we don't need
the climate problem to push that I think
you want better
observations at the subgrid scale level
I think you want more continuous Global
observations different variables I think
you need to engage professional
statisticians which they've not been
doing right now and you need more
thinking than Computing Kerry Emanuel
who's another mainstream distinguished
climate scientist at MIT who was happy
by the way to criticize my book before
you read it
um Kerry says more thinking and less
computing or at least more thinking not
necessarily more Computing or pencil and
paper I agree yeah right understanding
all right I have a very long question
but since he is a a past guest and a
friend of the podcast uh Tim Palmer who
authored a wonderful book we had him on
the podcast last year you can find that
I'll put a link somewhere up here he's
says the following it's a lengthy
question but here we go ahead climate
models are not perfect by a long way and
collectively they do not tell us how bad
climate change will be in unambiguous
terms at one end of the spectrum they
predict climate change outcomes which
could well be manageable by Society
without substantial mitigation right at
the other end they predict outcomes
which are catastrophic indeed
existential to much of society EG
through semi-continuous heat waves of a
severity that the human body cannot
withstand unless we do mitigate
the distribution of the possible climate
change is Peaks somewhere between these
two extrema and so we end up with
probabilistic estimates of climate
change but we are getting used to
probabilities in weather prediction if
the chance of rain is 20 this afternoon
will I bring my waterproofs my umbrella
in our afternoon hike if I do it will
weigh down my backpack making it someone
uncomfortable if I don't and I get the
drench it'll be extremely uncomfortable
so what to do it's a personal decision
not one that a meteorologist can make
given these estimates that are
probabilistic of climate change what is
your opinion on whether it is worth the
economic cost of trying to reach Net
Zero by 2050 like the weather forecast
is not a decision the climate scientists
can make on behalf of individual Society
um so for all of your concern about
skillfulness and realism of models how
have you decided is in his view is the
current estimated risk of catastrophic
climate change big enough to get to Net
Zero by 2050. I guess the one way to say
is there's an expected value right you
took the the probability of the negative
outcome the probability uh and the
impact economically human you know
impact all sorts of different impacts
and then you subtract the yeah the uh
the negative of those of those
possibilities so tell me have you I
guess how have you decided should we is
the risk is the Pascal's wager of
climate change I guess and and what I
would say is Tim is confusing his role
as a scientist
uh with his role as a citizen okay I
think his role as a scientist and mine
is to properly portray the probability
distribution to the decision makers
that's the broad society industry
politicians and not just in the U.S or
in the UK for the developing World okay
and what we have to do is to balance the
risks uncertainties and benefits of a
changing climate
against the growing need of the rest of
the world for Reliable
affordable and clean energy and in
weighing that balance it's a values
discussion it's risk tolerance
intergenerational equity and oh by the
way it's economics
if Tim were to ask that question
to a general person in Nigeria
he will get a very different answer
because those folks are facing a real
existential threat that is certain
immediate and soluble whereas the rest
of us it's vague on certain
probabilistic and so on I you know
there's a wonderful paper I'd like to
quote by a guy named Anthony Downs and
he was
um a political scientist Economist uh
died a year or two ago he was working at
Brookings but early in his career he was
working at UCLA
and in the 60s he was watching the smog
get worse and worse in the LA Basin and
it was getting worse in large part
because more and more people were
getting cars and what he said in this
wonderful paper he wrote was that the
elites environmental deterioration is
just the common man trying to improve
his heart and so Tim you go ask that
question in Nigeria okay and let's get a
hundred different voices from a hundred
countries together and decide what we're
going to do about this nobody has given
an answer that provides the energy needs
for the developing world and at the same
time gets to Net Zero by 2050. right and
so we have to you know think carefully
about these things that are
multi-coupled and I guess that may
answer the original question that I had
is why is this so fraught and perilous
politically we look out by the
constellation unless we're looking at a
comet or an asteroid coming to destroy
the Earth it doesn't involve existential
questions it may involve deeper meaning
philosophical questions Etc
um so okay great well Steve we've
reached the uh the final segment of the
podcast where I love to ask my esteemed
guests such as yourself for existential
questions which I call the final four
are the quintessential Quattro no yeah I
can't say quintessential the one that's
four things so the first thing and all
of them are somewhat related to Sir
Arthur C Clarke who is the namesake of
the center that I associatively direct
here at UC San Diego Arthur C Clarke
Center for human imagination right uh
and the first one has to do with this
very very famous quip which is that any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable for magic and my super
producer Stuart volkow is over there Hi
Stu always inserts that and every
podcast opening so you actually hear so
Arthur's voice saying those iconic words
I want to ask you in in sort of a big
picture not nothing related to the book
anymore
what invention or creation of humanity
is most closely evocative of magic you
know I often my father died in a
relatively young age about 45 years ago
um and
um
I often think what he would think if he
were alive today to see the tools we
have certainly information technologies
that we have are would have seen magic
to him I think
um and you know my other favorite is the
biology uh the advances that we've made
in understanding and manipulating how
living things work uh those are I would
assert indistinguishable from Magic to
people from as recently as 50 years ago
in the uh in the spirit of uh Sir Arthur
C Clarke the next question I like to ask
is the following he said and I quote the
only way to determine the limits of the
possible is to go beyond them into the
impossible and that's the name of this
podcast I want to ask you uh What uh
what former event in the form of advice
to your younger self maybe 20 year old
Steve what would you get advise him you
have 30 seconds to talk to old Steve or
young Steve would you advise them to
give him sort of the courage to do as
you've done bucking you know so many
scientists around the world and and in
in with facts and data
to go into the impossible in other words
advice to your former self you got a few
seconds to talk to you oh boy your 20
year old Steve you you know uh first of
all
um
don't feel inhibited by self-doubt by
lack of self-confidence you're no
different than everybody else you will
make mistakes but you'll learn from
those mistakes use your imagination but
also use the tools that you've been
given of logic quantitative
love for understanding how the world
works and go out and just have a swing
at it okay the next question is equipped
by Sir Arthur he said for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert and
we talked about feynman's quote that
science is the belief in the ignorance
of experts but as an expert should we
aspire to be an expert these two
gentlemen are kind of casting aspersions
on this one I used to think and I still
do to be honest with you that you should
aspire to Greatness you should aspire to
to Mastery and and Merit and and earning
um but but how do you react to that
should what what do we make of these uh
uh you know as um as William F Buckley
Juniors to say about the the he'd rather
be governed by the first hundred names
in the Boston phone book so what do you
make of experts do we need them are they
are they distinguished between experts
in The Sciences versus experts in other
fields absolutely and I think there are
two dimensions of expertise one is a
deep knowledge of the subject uh the
facts the figures what has been done
before uh and so on but then there's
another dimension which is I think a bit
pernicious and that is that you get
locked into certain ways of thinking
Community ways you know plight tectonics
is maybe the best example of where the
experts were all wrong and the evidence
was staring them in the face but it took
a long time until they came around so I
you know respect expertise for their
knowledge of the facts and figures but
not necessarily of the Paradigm that
they lay on top of the science very good
okay the last question inspired by Sir
Arthur C Clarke is the following he said
and I quote when an elderly I'm not
calling you elderly but an elderly but
distinguished scientist says something
is possible he is quite likely to be
right however when he says something is
impossible he is very likely to be wrong
what have you been wrong about oh boy I
was wrong about the soil neutrino
problem okay which yeah
uh there was this famous factor of uh
one-third uh deficit and I I think I've
actually said at a conference at some
point you know there's probably some
feature of the sauna plasma physics that
was wrong and and I was actually sitting
on a thesis at Caltech where it was
about coherent neutrino propagation and
he came so close to the what we now know
is the answer
um I you know I pooh-pooed it so that
can't be right so I was wrong okay but
you know look I would say a batting
average of one-third on uh like in
baseball on May of questions like that
would be doing pretty well so I've been
right about something they say you know
a theorist only has to be right once in
his life have a good career an
experimentalist only can be wrong once
in his career uh Professor Steve coonan
uh let me just take one quick question
detour what is the state of Academia
today what's it like at NY NYU is a very
I see it as a very
um uh imaginative I've talked to people
at NYU Abu Dhabi I know there's one in
Shanghai or someplace like that talk
about Academia what is the new model of
Academia look like and what can we do to
because you're a renowned teacher as
well most of education is sclerodically
stuck in the way it was in the
University of Bologna in 1080 A.D talk
about what Innovations we might expect
from the perspective of a master teacher
yeah so I'd like to distinguish the
undergraduates from the graduates of
course I think at the undergraduate
level you've got to become an expert in
something at least if you're going to be
in the Sciences t-shaped you know so
you've got I've learned your mathematics
you've got to learn biology geology
whatever it is you're going to
specialize in because that's the
pedestal on which you can then reach out
as a graduate student to try to tackle
some of these broader multi-disciplinary
problems I mean you know in my own
career I cut my teeth in nuclear physics
and it took me about oh 15 years after
my PhD to start to get interested in
these squirmier scientific problems
never mind the societal right problems
so I'd like to teach the kids the
undergraduate level
um you know 10 to the basics first get
some sense that there are these bigger
problems but don't try to tackle
something bigger until you've
demonstrated bastery of something first
yeah I was but then at The Graduate
level you know tackle those big problems
absolutely yeah I used to say to my
students you know if I was your art
teacher I'd say paint the Masters you do
the derivations that came before
exercises right gives a direct Pathway
to the so when I was a kid when I was
thinking about graduate school I said
they told me don't go into Nuclear
Physics is a dead field now we've got
Oppenheimer you guys are rock stars
literally have you seen the moves yet
not yet okay everybody's interested
right yeah everyone's interested so um
as someone who also served in the Obama
Administration worked in government what
do you say about people you know
scientists and and you know informing
people in Congress perhaps you see the
the tragedy that occurred to him and and
the persecution that he underwent
um you've been relentlessly attacked I
think in the media by colleagues and so
forth
um would you advise people to get into
to government or to serve the country in
such a way or would you have
reservations yeah so so
um you know you you cite some high
profile cases but I know many scientists
who work either as federal employees or
as
um in the National Laboratories uh and
they are as dedicated and as honest as
uh people in Academia you or I wouldn't
be we'd recognize them as as credible
scientists the problem is when that work
starts to touch policy issues and
whether it's epidemiology or its climate
and energy
environment other environmental issues
that's where sometimes people will spin
the story and not give a straight answer
you know I'm far enough along in my
career I've got enough of a reputation I
frankly don't care my main goal is to
just try to inform people in a
transparent unbiased way
and I guess lastly you know now with the
Advent of artificial intelligence large
language models and so forth
um I found it very exciting actually and
I'm playing around with it not only you
know as uh you know human interest level
of just you know constructing my own uh
what I call breibot um but but also uh
constructing physics um tools because I
do believe that we are stuck in a model
that's a thousand years old and how many
thousand-year-old things have not been
disrupted and I do believe we could have
things where we have distance learning
we have artificial Galileo I've worked
on because I have access to the written
text of the dialogue which I recorded
the first ever audiobook ever by Galileo
uh with Frank wilcheck and colleagues at
uh Carlo ravelli and others but um when
I think about the potential for that so
here at UCSD we had famous herb York I'm
sure you knew who plays a like maybe a
millisecond role in Oppenheimer we had
Harold Yuri who's a big component of the
Manhattan Project we had all these
people that were involved in gov
government and also in in organizations
but but the question I have is you know
how do we how do we translate whether or
not this is an existential threat an
existential benefit you know a boost to
society or not where are you falling in
this Camp of can artificial intelligence
lead to say new laws of physics perhaps
well we've seen it lead to new
strategies in go for example right and
you take an AI That's learned how to
play go and it surprises the Masters
right did it that way my God I never
thought about that right so I think
there are specialized AIS we can be
building uh physics is a great example
or even something more narrow and
general relativity for example that
would be tremendous tools for education
for research I mean even now of course
I'm sure you and others uh find as I do
Google just a wonderful way of ferreting
out information that um you need or
interest it in so I think the the AI
chat GPT for example
um will be when properly tuned wonderful
I'll give you my experience with chat
GPT all right and one of the things I'm
interested in is Greenland's ice loss
right and so I asked it this was a
couple months ago is Greenland Rose and
ice and I get kind of the standard media
story and then I said well what about
this paper that shows in fact it's not
losing is so rapidly and it took me
about four iterations until I got to
something that was consistent yes you
have to supervise research yeah you've
got to keep correcting it but um I think
it's got a lot of potential so I'm not
worried about an existential threat I
think it will be a great boon well Steve
coonan Professor I think of you as an
educator as a as a curious Soul as
somebody who's very much interested in
solving the biggest problems whether
it's at the realm of the smallest
possible entities nuclei and Quantum
Fields all the way up to entire
planetary scale phenomena I want to
thank you for spending so much of your
valuable time here with our humble
podcast and I know our audience is
forever great it's a great conversation
thank you so much